good morning rich how are you DP I'm
doing great he's doing a beautiful
sunshine 68 degrees here in st. Andrews
couldn't be better just before the round
yesterday what did you expect out of
Tiger Woods I didn't think he'd win
I thought he'd play well I just didn't
feel like he was ready started to change
my thinking at about the tempo and the
world and the world was going bananas in
fact there's a famous little pub here in
st. Andrews a stone's throw from the
18th green called the Dunvegan he'd been
over here you know it yep and it was
jam-packed I'm told yesterday TV's on
and the place was going bonkers for
Tiger Woods but here in st. Andrews I
mean it was the highest rated final
round of the open since 2006 when Tiger
won at Liverpool there's something
magical about it that it's sort of as it
becomes bigger than golf it becomes
bigger than sports it became a look you
know that then it was your curiosity
seekers right this was I felt we started
thinking about it because we thought we
were going to have to deliver the story
which would have been one of the biggest
stories I think of our lifetime in
sports I mean this was a recent vintage
into a tiger wing give him where he was
was the Cubs winning the World Series
for the first time in more than a
century it was LeBron down 3-1 to Golden
State bringing an NBA title to the land
it was it was something on that scale
and it was real at your midway through
the afternoon and I mean it was as
bananas a final round that I can
remember at one point you had a half
dozen guys tied for the lead at 6-under
and and some of the names were it was
woods it was Justin Rose it was jordan
Spieth it was Rory McIlroy and as is so
often the case mr. vanilla you know mr.
plain with with all due respect because
he is a phenomenal player all of the
sudden Francesco Molinari wins
now did you pipe in the sound behind you
is this sort of like CBS at
with those sorry yes it's very very
masters issue with the seagulls here hey
by the way you know is one of the the
hidden really cool stories yesterday was
Eddie Pepperell shooting 67 the
Englishmen posting 5-under leading in
the clubhouse five hours before we were
going to finish and and letting the
press know that he just did shoot 67 on
one of the hardest course in the world
while hungover which which harkens back
to the old days when when pro golfers
didn't go to David Leadbetter were Butch
Harmon first or Sean Foley for swing
advice they went to Jim Beam Jack
Daniels and John Walker who were some of
the finest instructors
and anybody who's ever played right any
of your listeners they know if it's
going sideways through nine you're a
little tight just a couple of pops at
the turn and suddenly you find your
groove
how much drinking do you think went on
previous generation on tour copious
amounts was I mean it was brown liquor
and unfiltered cigarettes and that was
the era of Ben Hogan they didn't you
know nobody went to the gym they didn't
travel with trainers what she did was
long train ride that was hanging out in
hotel bars get nice pair of slacks
wherever you went you put a sports coat
on and maybe a tie yeah I think they got
after it he's rich Lerner Golf Channel
anchor reporter and play-by-play man for
the senior open at st. Andrews that'll
be Thursday through Sunday at Golf
Channel and NBC what's the one thing
that people should see when they go to
st. Andrews
hmm the road hole if your golf or go
stand by the road hole and try to figure
it out try to figure out what what is
all the fuss about you you you tee off
and you're aiming for room 344 of the
old horse hotel they're like I don't get
it
and most of us will part one you know at
about room 344 right of the tea and and
then you know up by the green is it like
like four yards from today where the
hole was set at four yards from the hole
is this road and at a stone wall and you
you get two Sooners you're like well I
don't really get it and even 18 this
Wilkin bridge you have everybody stops
to have the picture taken where Arnie
and Jack and Tom Watson they all said
farewell in the RNAs behind the green
the old
stone facade and you say stop much of a
golf hole it's three hundred and
thirty-some yards straight away there's
nothing there except hundreds of years
of history and it's such a charming
quaint little town we just we're in a
bookstore I bought you know just some
lunch reading Yubel Noah her Ahri's
sapiens a brief history of mankind 466
pages of of easy-breezy reading here on
a anyway you know it's like if you're a
golfer it's a month you need to you need
to come I'll leave you with this finish
the sentence if Tiger had won the Open
Championship yesterday
we'd be buzzing about it for weeks
we'd be thinking about documentaries I
just don't think he's ready dan I know
the hunger and ambition are there that's
obvious I think the talent is polished
to a point where absolutely good enough
I just don't think competitively he's
quite ready it's almost like a young
golfer who needs you and this sounds
strange to say of the all time no doubt
about it guy he he has doubt again he
needs to be in the heat over and over
again and figure out how to handle
himself
because he had this one in his sights I
mean one shot lead he had birdied eleven
three straight days and then made double
and we've seen this Tiger has not been
very good and the plate has come back on
the back nine but he's the show he moves
the needle like no one else and it was
was really exciting I think the other
story yesterday was speak hard to figure
there's a vulnerability with Jordan
that's part of his appeal fidget ease
jumpy but he's the great quarterback who
will throw two interceptions and then
come back the next game and thread the
needle from 20 yards to win you a big
one and then yet you have to tip your
cap to Molinari it's rare in sports
I maybe it's nick foles ish I don't know
Kurt Warner when somebody who has
regarded us as a journeyman and their
mid 30
and and maybe he's just great for two
months I don't know but it looks like
he's really figured something out he has
a little magic now around the greens to
go with his peerless
Tina green games so there you go was it
was a it was a great one it would have
been an epic had Tiger won but the story
lives for another day maybe the PGA
Championship rich was great to talk to
you have fun tell the boys I said alone
we'll be watching this week deeply
thanks for having me all the best talk
soon
that's a rich Lerner Golf Channel anchor
and reporter and handling
play-by-play duties the senior open at
st. Andrews Thursday through Sunday Golf
Channel and NBC yeah this is gonna be
one of those tournaments where you go oh
by the way Francesco Molinari ended up
winning there and people look at him and
say well he doesn't do anything great
he'd just steady but Tiger playing with
Molinari said he played beautiful golf
because on those courses if you haven't
played those courses man it can go
sideways so quickly well you lose the
ball you go out of bounds and to be able
to hit fairway
green to putt and then I kept thinking
he's got to have a birdie down the
stretch if he's gonna win this and then
he had two birdies down the stretch but
I believe the numbers in his last three
tournaments and somebody can help me
with this last three tournaments he's
played on the weekend a total of one
bogey that's playing great golf and he
played you know under par golf on
Saturday and Sunday to win a major and I
have no problems with that at all but it
was what it was a lot of fun to watch
and that environment and those are
knowledgeable golf fans and and just see
the different lies that you have and you
know what they have to deal with
it's just something completely different
than anything they faced all year long
for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience Channel 239 on Direct TV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]